the circle is arguably the most
fundamental shape in our universe
whether you look at the shapes of of
orbits of planets whether you look at
wheels whether you look at things on
kind of a molecular level the circle
just keeps showing up over and over and
over again so it's probably worthwhile
for us to understand some of the
properties of the circle so the first
thing when people kind of discover the
circle and you know you just have to
look at the moon to see a circle but the
first time they say well you know what
what are the properties of any circle so
the first one they might want to say is
well a circle
is all of the points that are equal
distant from the center of the circle
right all of these points along the edge
are equal distant from that center right
there so one of the first things someone
might want to ask is what is that
distance that equal distance that
everything is from the center
right there
we call that the radius
the radius
of the circle it's just the distance
from the center out to the edge if that
radius is three centimeters then this
radius is going to be three centimeters
and
this radius is going to be three
centimeters it's never going to change
by definition a circle is all of the
points that are equidistant from the
center point and that distant is that
distance is the radius
now the next most interesting thing
about that people might say well how fat
is the circle how how how wide is it
along its widest point or if you just
want to cut it along its widest point
what is that distance right there and it
doesn't have to be just right there i
could have just as easily cut it along
its widest point right there i just
wouldn't be cutting it
like some place like that because that
wouldn't be along its widest point
there's multiple places where i could
cut it along its widest point
well we just saw the radius
and we see that widest point goes
through the center and just keeps going
so it's essentially two radii
you get one
radius there and then you have another
radius over there and we call
this distance
along the widest point on the circle the
diameter
so that is the diameter of the circle
it has a very easy relationship with the
radius the diameter
the diameter is equal to two times
two times the radius
two times the radius now the next most
interesting thing that you might be
wondering about a circle is how far is
it around the circle so if you were to
get your tape measure out and you were
to measure around
around the circle like that
if you were to measure around the circle
like that what's that distance
we call that word the circumference
circumference
circumference of the circle
now we know how the diameter and the
radius relates but how does the
circumference relate to say the diameter
and if we know how it releases the
diameter it's very easy to figure out
how to release the to the radius
well many thousands of years ago people
took their tape measures out and they
keep measuring circumferences and
radiuses and let's say when their tape
measures weren't so good they you know
let's say they measure the circumference
of the circle and they would get it well
it looks like it's about three
and then they measure the radius of this
circle right here
and they or the diameter of that circle
and they say well that diameter looks
like it's about one so they would say
let me write this down so we're worried
about we're worried about the ratio
let me write it like this the ratio
of
the
circumference
circumference to
the diameter
to
the diameter so let's say that you know
somebody had some circle over here let's
say they had this circle and the first
time with not that good of a tape
measure they measured around the circle
and they said hey it's roughly equal to
three meters when i go around it and
when i measure the diameter of the
circle it's roughly equal to one
okay that's interesting it may be the
ratio of the circumference of the
diameter is three so maybe the
circumference is always three times the
diameter well that was just for this
circle but it'll say they measured some
other circle here let's say it's like
this i drew it smaller but let's say
that on this circle they measured around
it
and they found out that the
circumference
is six centimeters roughly they have a
bad tape measure right then and then
they find out that the diameter the
diameter is roughly two centimeters and
once again the ratio of the
circumference to the diameter
circumference to diameter was roughly
three it's like hey this is a neat
property of circles maybe the ratio of
the circumference to the diameter is
always fixed for any circle so they said
let me study this further so they got
better tape measures when they got
better tape measures they measured hey
you know my diameter is definitely one
they say my diameter is definitely one
but when i measure my circumference a
little bit i realize it's more it's
closer to 3.1
closer to 3.1 and the same thing with
this over here they notice that this
ratio is closer to 3.1 and then they
kept measuring it better and better and
better and then they realized that it
was they were getting this number
they just kept measuring it better and
better and better and they were getting
this number 3.1415
and they just kept adding digits and it
would never repeat and it was a strange
fascinating metaphysical number that
kept showing up and so since this number
was so fundamental to our universe
because the circle is so fundamental to
our universe and it just showed up
it just showed up for every circle the
ratio of the circumference diameter was
this kind of magical number they gave it
a nut they gave it a name
they called it pie
or you could just give it the
latin or the greek letter
pi
just like that
that represents this number which is
arguably the most fascinating number in
our universe it first shows up as the
ratio of the circumference to the
diameter but you're going to learn as
you as you go through your mathematical
journey that it shows up everywhere it's
one of these fundamental things about
the universe that just makes you think
that there's some some order to it but
anyway how can we use this in our in our
in our in our just i guess our basic
mathematics so we know or i'm telling
you that the ratio of the circumference
circumference
to the diameter when i say the ratio
it's literally i'm just saying if you
divide the circumference by the diameter
but by the diameter
you're going to get pi
pi is just this number i could write
3.14159 and just keep going on and on
and on but that would be a waste of
space and it would just be hard to deal
with so people just write this greek
letter pi there
so how can we relate this we can
multiply both sides of this that by the
diameter and we could say
that the circumference is equal to pi
times the diameter
or since the diameter is equal to two
times the radius we could say that the
circumference is equal to
pi
times two times the radius or the form
that you're most likely to see it it's
equal to
2 pi
r so let's see if we can apply that to
some problems
so let's say i have a circle
i have a circle just like that
and i were to tell you it has a radius
its radius right there is three
so three let me write this down so the
radius
is equal to three maybe it's 3 meters
put some units in there what is the
circumference of the circle
the circumference is equal to 2 times pi
times the radius so it's going to be
equal to 2
times pi
times the radius times
times 3 meters which is equal to 6
meters times pi or 6 pi meters
6 pi
meters now i could multiply this out
remember pi is just a number pi is
3.14159
going on and on and on so if i multiply
6 times that maybe i'll get you know 18
point something something something i'll
get some if you have your calculator you
might want to do it but for simplicity
people just tend to leave our numbers in
terms of pi now i don't know what this
is if you multiply 6 times
3.14159 i know if you get something
close to 19 or 18 maybe it's
approximately 18 point something
something something i don't have my
calculator in front of me but instead of
writing that number you just write 6 pi
there actually yeah i think it wouldn't
quite cross the threshold to 19 yet now
what if i were to go there well let's
ask another question what is the
diameter of the circle
what is the diameter
well if this radius is 3 the diameter is
just twice that
so it's just going to be 3 times 2 or 3
plus 3 which is equal to 6 meters so the
circumference is 6 pi meters the
diameter is 6 meters the radius is 3
meters now let's go the other way let's
say i have another circle
let's say i have another circle here
and i were to tell you that it's
circumference the circumference is equal
to
10 meters that's the circumference of
the circle if you were to put a tape
measure to go around it and someone were
to ask you what is the diameter
what is the diameter of the circle
well we know that the diameter times pi
we know that pi times the diameter
is equal to the circumference
is equal to 10 meters so to solve for
this we would just divide both sides of
this equation by pi so the diameter
would equal 10 meters
over pi or 10 over
pi meters and that is just a number if
you have your calculator you could
actually divide 10 divided by
3.14159 you're going to get 3 point
something something something meters i
can't do it in my head but this is just
a number but for simplicity we often
just leave it that way
now what what is the radius well the
radius is equal to one-half the diameter
so this whole distance right here is 10
over pi meters and if we just want half
of that if we just want the radius we
just multiply it times half so you have
one half
times 10 over pi which is equal to one
half times 10 or you could just say
this divide the numerator and the
denominator by 2
you get a 5 there so you get 5 over pi
so the radius over here is 5 over pi
nothing super fancy about this i think
the thing that
confuses people the most is to just
realize that pi is a number pi is just
3.14159 it just keeps going on and on
and on you could there's there's you
could write there's there's actually
thousands of books written about pi so
it's not like you know and then
i don't know if there's thousands but
maybe i'm exaggerating but you could
write books about this number but it's
just a number it's a very special number
and if you wanted to write it in a way
that you're used to writing numbers you
can literally just multiply this out but
most of the time people just realize
they like leaving things in terms of pi
anyway i'll leave you there in the next
video we'll figure out the area of a
circle